In this video, I will show you my last
six trades on NQ with four wins, two
losses, and $14,000 in profits. I'm
going to walk you through every single
trade, exactly why I took it, where I
entered, what happened. Let's go. And
real quick, before I forget, if you are
new here and have no idea about my
strategy, pause this video right now. Go
watch my full strategy breakdown in the
description. Watch that first, then come
back and every trade in this video will
make complete sense. For everyone who
are already using my strategy, let's go
into trade number one. We will start
with this trade on Monday, 11th of May.
So, here we can go see the charts.
Like you know, I always take one trade
per day. This day, I saw that the EMAs
are 100% bullish, waited for the market
to open. I've seen a big green candle
here who inversed multiple fair value
gaps right here before market open, but
when I tried to enter right here and put
my stop loss, it was so big. This is the
first reason why I didn't enter. Plus,
the market was ranging since the start
of the week, as you can see right here.
So, market weren't technically not
trending in this day. So, we had an
opening of the week right here. We had a
big New York opening candle. The stop
loss was so big. I waited for fair value
gap to form inside the New York session.
After we inversed this fair value gap, I
entered, put my stop loss under the
previous candle, and targeted 2R's, but
I had a loss. And even if I placed my
stop loss at the swing low, the stop
loss was inevitable on this day. This is
purely a statistical loss. So, my
strategy will have wins and losses, and
you can't escape from the losses. Even
if I used a pre-market FVG like this
one, and I entered at the opening of the
New York session, and placed my stop
loss right here. I was going to be
stopped out whatever I do. Like I said,
this was the trade from Monday. It was a
loss. Let's jump into the next day.
As you can see here, the market is
clearly trending down. We are printing
lower highs and lower lows from the
beginning of the day. My bias was purely
bearish for this day. I waited for the
New York session to start and as you can
see, we only have this bullish fair
value gap inside the counter trend that
was formed pre-market. So, when the
price inverted in this candle right
here, I did go in, placed my stop loss
above the candle which inverted the FVG
because it was a momentum candle and the
stop loss is 370 ticks. And since we
have no previous liquidity that we can
target, I targeted two hours. This was
an easy trade. As you can see, we are
below all the EMAs. We inverted this
bullish fair value gap. I simply
entered, placed my stop loss above the
inversion candle and targeted two hours.
On this day, I made $4,300.
And like you see here on my calendar, I
only take one trade per day. Now, let's
jump to the next day.
Here, you can see that we are purely
bullish. We kept printing higher highs
and higher lows. Then, we had a pretty
big sell off right here, but the EMAs
kept pointing up. That means after the
New York open, I waited for this drama
to be over. This is the only bearish
fair value gap that we have in this part
right here. I kept waiting for the price
to invert it. It have failed multiple
[snorts] times. Then, after inverting
this fair value gap right here, I
entered, placed my stop loss under the
fair value gap and also under the
inversion candle. and if you can notice
under this green EMA, and targeted this
previous liquidity right here. The RR
was 2.5, and the trade went straight to
TP. This was from Wednesday, 13th of
May. As you can see here, 5K. Now, let's
jump to the next day.
It's clearly showing that the EMAs are
purely bullish. So, my bias was bullish
that day. We can see these two fair
value gaps.
They are very small. Then, after market
opened, it inversed them both. That's
why I entered, put my stop loss under
the last FVG that was inversed, and
targeted previous liquidity. The RR was
also 2.5. As you know, I don't move my
stop loss to the break even. That's why
I've been able to catch this full trade.
And before I forget something, you can
see right here on Thursday that the
price action was similar to Monday. So,
you can see here Thursday, and you can
see Monday. The only difference why I
didn't take this first opening candle on
Monday, and I took it on Thursday, was
the size of the candle. The entry here
was also viable. I was going to be
stopped out whether I took an FVG from
pre-market or after market. This was a
losing day, no matter what I do. And
like I said, the only difference was the
size of the opening candle. So, this day
was Thursday, 14th of May. As you can
see here, 5.03K.
Now, let's jump to the next day.
As you can see here, EMAs are pointing
down. The price is under the EMAs. Also,
the market is printing lower highs and
lower lows since the start of the Asian
session. We have a clear bullish fair
value gap right here. Let me zoom in. We
inversed it with this candle. I entered,
placed my stop loss at the high of the
inversion candle, but it was also a
statistical loss. I cannot do anything
to avoid this loss. You can see here the
whole day we didn't get a profitable
entry until the end of the day right
here at this small bullish fair value
gap. This was going to be a winning
trade, but like you know, I always take
one trade per day. I always take the
first opportunity that I see. I have no
problem being stopped out as long as I
execute my system like a robot. This day
was Friday the 15th of May. I lost 2K
with it. Now, let's jump into the next
day, which is today.
As you can see, the New York session
started right here. We are below the
1-hour EMA.
If we zoom in, we will see that we are
trending down since Thursday. We have
this fair value gap. Price inversed it,
but stayed above the 1-hour EMA. That's
why I didn't take this trade. Then, we
inversed the next fair value gap. I
entered right here, placed my stop loss
over the inversion candle, over the fair
value gap, and also over the 1-hour EMA.
That means I have three layers of
protection. I targeted this previous
liquidity right here. This was a 2R
trade. I regret on not targeting this
liquidity here. It would have been a
very good trade with 6R's, but we play
with probabilities right here. That
means I take trades that have the
highest probability. This trade was 7
minutes long. I took this trade and call
it a day. This was a trade from the 18th
of May, Monday. I made 4.14K
with it. And like I said, I regret on
not targeting that liquidity that I
showed you, but it is what it is. No
problem with that. And if you are still
watching, I want to talk with you for a
second. You've been using this strategy,
you know the rules, you've put in the
screen time, but you are not where you
want to be yet. You are close enough to
see it, you are just not consistent. And
the gap between knowing what to do and
doing it every single day is the gap
that costs you money, a lot of money,
and so much time. I work with a small
number of people one-on-one. It's not a
course, it's not a signal group, it's
not a Discord community. Just me and
you, every single day, working both on
technical execution and psychology to
make sure that you start being
consistent, being funded, getting
payouts, and the most important one, to
make sure that you win. I work with a
very small number of people who are
willing to put the work. If you are done
giving your money away to prop firms and
wasting years strategy hoping, check the
link in the description down below.